SEASON, AND THE FOURTH OF HIS
CAREER.
THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS, GREAT NEWS
SETS UP KAGHT.
PETE DeBOER SAID HE
THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS.
HERE'S A LOOK FOR THE
WRAPAROUND.
GOOD JOB ON
UP AHEAD, JANMARK BREAKAWAY TO
THE NET!
HE SENDS JANMARK IN ALL ALONE.
A COBRETT HOWDEN HAS IT NOW BUM
BY KOPITAR.
COGHLAN FOR  TO THE LINEUP THUR
ANTEMPEH MOVES IT UP
AHEAD FOR ALEX IAFALLO.
IT LEADS TO A JONATHAN HERE.
LEADS THE KINGS WITH
SHORT SIDE.
HE IS GOING TO BANK THIS
BETWEEN TH
BIG SAVE BY PETERSEN WE HAVE SE
KIND OF NEW SET UP WITH  Dave:
MARCHESSAULT, AND THEY SCORE! T
JUST A TON OF SPEED ON THE
RUSSIAN WHAT 11 GAMES.
SHANE MENTIONED A NEW CAREER-
HIGH AT 15 ON NOW AND
IT'S A REAL GOOD PLAY DOWN LOW
AS MOORE WITH A COND
EFFORT!
HE PUT
FOREHAND.
HERE'S THE MISSED SHOT.
DURZI  GOT  FOR THEIR SECOND
>> Shane: GREAT PLAY BY HIM TO
CHANDLER STEPHENSON, NEW CAREER-
HIGH IN GOALS. FIELD.
NOW, KOPITAR. ve:  I KNOW YOU A
WE APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS.
>> Shane: YOU ARE MY PAIN.
>> Dave: [
ALEX PIETRANGELO, HE HITS
DOUBLE DIGITS AND GOALS FOR THE
RIGHT IN FRONT
THE SAVE AND THEN VILARDI
COMING BACK TO HELP UP.
IT GOES OFF PETERSEN'S